it has been claimed by several authors
and websites that these spectacular
elongated skulls of Peru cannot be
normal humans because the skulls are
missing a sagittal suture the line that
they claim always runs along the top of
human skulls they also claim that many
of the elongated skulls possess two
small holes on the back of the head
these holes they say do not exist in
normal humans are these claims correct
could these skulls really belong to
aliens from outer space or could they as
proposed by others represent hybrids
between humans and fallen angels you are
watching episode 4 of citizen science
versus the aliens of Peru
hello everybody john perry here i'm with
my nephew and today we are going to talk
about sagittal suture z-- Jackson what
is a sagittal suture yeah it's this
particular line on the skull it goes
from about the middle of the head
backwards that is the sagittal suture
and all mammals have these I can even
show you on a dog yes this is a French
Bulldog and you can see the sagittal
suture is this line right here towards
the back of the skull going backwards
that is the sagittal suture so all
mammals have these when they're young
sometimes they lose them when they get
older but the elongated skull is missing
a sagittal suture so I can show this to
you here on the camera you see that this
bone here is totally smooth yes
so we'll suture in the front right here
this is the coronal suture she's got
that so that's that matches this suture
right here but she's missing the
sagittal suture
and people on the internet claim that
because many of the elongated skulls are
missing surgical sutures they clean that
that is evidence that these must be
aliens or nonhumans of some kind if all
humans have sagittal suture it would be
strange that she does not have one but
guess what Jackson but not all humans
have sagittal suture
I have here Thank You sealed a baby
skull this is it yeah the creepiest
thing that I own it's a replica it's not
a real baby skull but in this skull you
can see very clearly that it has a
suture in the front of the skull it's
cut this line down the front of the
skull this one right on adults that line
does not exist that suture leaves we
call this suture obliteration so what
happens when a skull is growing you can
actually see it really well on this
baby's skull you see how there's points
right here and kind of on the forehead
yeah bone when this baby was even
younger when it's still fetus it's
entire skull was made mostly of
cartilage the skulls bones start out as
cartilage and at little points right
here and right here bones started to
grow and it's grown and grown and grown
and it's met in the middle that's why
sutures exist because bones are growing
and they meet in the middle and where
they meet we find sutures and this
happened on the forehead as well well
this suture at about two years old
actually can start it can happen as
early as three months old three to nine
months but definitely by about two years
old almost all humans go through what's
called suture obliteration for the
frontal suture the suture on the front
here and that means that the bone gets
so tight together and then grows into
the other bone and it becomes one bone
completely suture obliteration as a
person continues to mature normally they
maintain the sagittal suture for quite
some time but we have found that at
about the age of 40 somewhere between 40
and 70 the sagittal suture will also go
through suture obliteration people will
completely lose their suture oh well so
that could have happened
this way that could have happened her
she might be old she might be over 40
years old and that's why she's missing a
sagittal suture if you get onto a
forensic website you know what Forensic
Sciences it's people forensic scientists
people that study crime scenes and they
say they want to know if they find a
dead person it's just a skeleton they
want to know how old that person was
they want to know you know what gender
they want to try to identify that person
and if they're just a skeleton it can be
really hard right but they have found
that by looking at the obliteration of
sutures they can kind of get a rough
estimate about how old that person was
because you know from about the age of
40 to 70 the sagittal suture will
obliterate this is a well-known fact
people have been using this in forensic
science for years and years and years
and the fact that websites like guy.com
don't recognize that or don't tell their
audience that instead they use this as
some sort of a scam to say that this
thing is an alien that's really really
dishonest you know so that was one of
the claims that people made is that the
fact that she's missing a sagittal
suture means that she must be an alien
the other claim that they made is that
the elongated skulls usually have two
holes on the back at the head she
actually has one that's visible here and
people like Brian foresters say that
these holes only exist in elongated
skulls they're not right that is not
true we look at a normal human skull we
can find that it too has holes on the
back of its skull yep not only the
skulls
often have these holes but they have
them so often that people have actually
named them they are called the parietal
for raymond's have a scientific name and
not all people have them depending on
your lineage you have about a 50% chance
of having them or up to an 80% chance of
having them certain family lines are
more like
parietal freeman than other family lines
and what happens is this little hole
there's a blood vessel that will go
through it into the cavity above the
brain if you have it if you don't have
it there's other there's a bunch of
other blood vessels that go up there as
well there's a it's like an extra hole
for a blood vessel to go through the
only some people have people have been
researching this for a long time they're
very common and I've got a paper that
people can look at and read for
themselves if they want it's all about
parietal foramen the percentage of
people that have them versus the
percentage that don't and a lot of the
elongated skulls have them and a lot of
them are fairly large and the elongated
skulls if you look at this guy's you can
see that this one is fairly large that
one is tiny
it also looks very faint yeah it's very
faint and it's probably almost closed up
there probably wasn't a blood vessel
going through that hole at least when he
was an adult maybe there was when he was
younger but they vary in size from
person to person and sometimes they vary
number some people only have one most
people have two if they have them or
some people have none at all she happens
to have one and it's fairly large so
both of these claims that this can't be
a human because it's missing a sagittal
suture and she can't be a human because
she has this hole in the back of her
head both of those claims are completely
fraudulent the people who are making
these claims it's very obvious that they
do not know anything about skull Anatomy
it's very obvious that they have not
said in the last video people dress up
in the scientific coat even though
they're not even scientists right hey
you know the guy that the guy that's
been making these claims he calls
himself a researcher but he's actually a
tour guide I mean he is doing research
okay but he's he's not familiar with the
research that's already been done on
skulls he's not familiar with the
scientific literature and if you would
just take some time to read some
textbooks read some of the scientific
literature again I have links to all the
papers to talk about this in the video
description he he wouldn't get confused
in a way that he has been so
there we have it next week
is going to be very exciting because we
are going to actually measure these
skulls we're going to get the actual
volume of these skulls and we're going
to see once and for all if the elongated
skull really is 25% larger than the
normal human skull so ladies and
gentlemen until next time stay curious
all right
[Music]
you